[Music]
that's Olympic gold medalist Sean
Johnson and her husband Andrew east just
moments after the arrival of their baby
girl drew a couple documented the entire
birthing experience in a video posted to
their YouTube channel which included
footage from their first pregnancy in
2017 no longer pregnant 2019 the pair
got pregnant again and when it came time
to deliver little drew Sean spent 22
hours in labor the baby was not moving
and Sean's body was just a little too
small and her hips were too tight
because of her past and athletics that
after they broke the water they could
only wait so long and so she just went
back to the operating room get a
c-section the delivery was a success the
new mom and dad spent some quality time
bonding with their baby
[Music]
days after drew was born Shawn took to
Instagram to share some sweet photos and
reveal the inspiration behind her
daughter's name Shawn wrote quote named
after the most incredible person I know
her daddy 20 and a half inch baby girl
[Laughter]
Shawn has always blown us away with her
commitment to her sport and dedication
to giving back here's what she told ET
about inspiring the next generation and
why she loves working with kids I love
it I love talking to kids and especially
gymnast because you know when I was
little and you know starting to get
serious with gymnastics I really wished
I had someone close to my age like I
relate to and talk to and ask questions
and that's why I love coming to gyms and
talking and I just love it their little
faces like light up and they watch me in
the Olympics and I just I hope that I
can help them get there some way too
[Music]